Recently while watching a movie with my right, I must have been the core going into the bulb that I got, and it got really hot,
birdied hot, and it smelled like birdied electronics. After the, after that, the bulb seems to be working normally and not overheating.
Was that just an odd occurrence? Should I assume it's working properly?
I think what you're saying is at the end, like where it connects to the bulb, to the, to the inside of the bulb, you, that got bent and that got hot right there.
Is that what, if that's what you're saying, or is it that you bent it where it connects to the right for sheet itself?
If you, let's, let's use this first option, if you bend this and it got really hot here, the danger is banging this or bending this can, can break the connection of these wires here.
I think you could see my cursor, right? These wires go in, and this is an RF blocker, so it's one of those little RF shields, so that wire goes in and it connects to the bulb itself.
If that connection breaks, then the bulb isn't going to work.
If that broke, then the bulb would not work anymore, so you didn't break that connection.
And if that connection breaks, then it's not fixable either.
What I started doing with the bulbs, and you could do this, I have a Velcro strip.
So you're, you're probably looking at this picture going, my mom doesn't look like that. What is this black thing? And why is this looped here? What is this black thing holding the cord there? Is that just for transport?
No, that is to prevent what you're saying.
So we have recently got a number of people act as to the last mud, they're having their bulb not working.
And as I got their bulb back, it was broken, that connection where that wire goes in, and you can't see it behind this white plastic thing where the wire connects to the glass tube.
This is just a packing material where it connects to the glass tube that was broken. So what happened was the person must have dropped the bulb and it landed on the end here.
And the person, you know, you know, was laid with it and it got pulled inadvertently didn't see that or you rolled over and pulled it inadvertently and it just it broke that connection and it looks perfectly fine.
And it looks like there's nothing wrong with the bulb. How come it doesn't work?
I would have just just broken that connection. So I went back to way back in the day when Mike owned true right what we used to do is zip tie the bulb like this. Now I used Velcro straps he used with him.
We used two big black zip ties and we looped the cord like this and black zip tie. You could use electrical tape, you could use duct tape, whatever you want to do to hold the cord.
So it gave a little slack here.
The cord has a little bit of slack so that, you know, it helps prevent it getting pulled out. So if you accidentally pulled on it, I rolled it over in batter, you pulled on it because you moved on, shifted on the culture, whatever, it wouldn't pull that out.
This is the first time I'm making the suggestion that people do this. It just gives added protection to the bulb. Now currently I'm sending all bulbs out like this with these Velcro straps.
Will it help prevent damage? I think it will help.
Does it look goofy? I don't care if it looks goofy. I don't think you care if it looks goofy. You want your bulb to last. You don't want to buy a new bulb.
So I think doing that with your bulb may help prevent exactly what you, I'm glad you asked this question because I was going to bring this up and show this picture like completely forgot to add it to the slides today.
And now see how God works. So just make a loop like this. Leave this loose. Use duct tape or if you have Velcro straps or if you have, you know, zip ties or whatever you want to do it.
Hold that down so that it will help at least give some added protection of you pulling that cord out and could prolong the life of your bulb.
So if it is bad, it's something or if as long as the bulb is working, it's working. So but just check and see that it's not heat up the cord or something. Just keep checking that.